I'm here at the Intel baruch central
synagogue when i come for a reason I've
long been intrigued by Judaism I work
with many Jewish people have many Jewish
friends and I want to find out what all
the fuss was about
so I thought maybe while I'm here in Tel
Aviv I could quickly convert to Judaism
and down the Jewish myself I have about
an hour and 25 minutes to absorb 4,000
years of culture and deeply held
religious belief this is rabbi
Halliburton very good very good
I got a right harbour top thank you very
much for agreeing to meet with me thank
you it's my gonna what's involved for me
to convert first of all you come in
front of the court the Jewish code this
is the first stage was pure I'm clearly
we're secondly you have to be a virgin
with pure oh I think man had to be a
virgin because up to five years ago I've
been five one who converts yes
is it like he was born from today that's
fantastic
that's unbelievable and it means that
you thought you don't have father you
don't have a mother you don't have
sister you can marry them it's not so
easy to marry them but I mean wait a
minute I can marry my sister
conceptually you can marry her because
you are not you you born from now yes
and you are not you have no sisters
rabbi
listen if you had if you have publicist
here they'd be pulling you out
on a back road I know you didn't need it
that way but you sort of said we're very
selective religion but the minute you
join it you can marry your sister I know
you didn't mean that it's like you were
born today yes isn't that's the part
amazing that's the part I like I said
right you men I'm a new man everything
I've done before
no oh you know nothing I could have
committed but you were better before and
then now is he still studying to get in
[Applause]
what is the sukoon sighs sighs if I am
NOT circumsized I have to become
circumcised that's an amazing question
it's a huge question I go there with a
face pretty simple question see there we
need everything I got down there
we can't be we can't you know I mean I'm
fine down there but I don't want to lose
any of it it's very difficult for me to
truly become Jewish [ __ ] and there many
sacrifices and my place might have to be
eviscerated that said I'm very much
interested in having a Bar Mitzvah
without doing nothing do you start by
mixing means that a boy come to beat a
minute yes I'd like to become a man I
remember dirt bike people got amazing
stuff so in the interstate near the gut
books they put a yeah like this one you
know one of those boots
that's what we mind that's the last
thing he needs is another book a dirt
bike by the way I could bring it to you
but he's reading The Da Vinci Code I
feel good do I look Jewish to you it
begins sucks right okay
so steam whistle three something the
shore feeling the tender hub the whole
sharifa detained the hub local Larissa I
said I said
[Applause]
this is amazing the theme tonight is
boys man okay I understand that
traditional at the bar mitzvah for me to
get gifts is that right rabbi oh yeah
I don't know what that meant but the
rabbi just said good money everyone come
forward that's good it's cash only I
don't want any checks my bar mitzvah
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you